now you someone who's voted for a brexit
deal unlike some of your colleagues and
you concerned by the resignation if I'm
arrived where she simply says that she
doesn't believe that getting a deal as
the government's main objective of
course I'm concerned Sophie you know at
the heart of all this is trust can we
trust the Prime Minister Boris Johnson
to do what he said he would do which is
work to achieve a deal and on the other
side of it is can we trust those who
often also don't want to do because they
want to overturn the referendum result
of 2016 and that's why myself and others
have formed a group called MPs for a
deal because there is still a heartfelt
desire amongst many MPs across all
parties to get a deal before the 31st of
October but others have to play their
part and chief of those is the prime
minister you talked about your group of
MPs trying to get a deal there's been
bills put forward to try and say can we
please have a chance to vote when
Theresa Mays deal again now you voted
for Theresa Mays deal are you a bit
frustrated by some of your colleagues
who have had a bit of a late conversion
to it they weren't prepared to hold
their noses and vote for it last time
but now they are happy to do it
once the ships out well we're not saying
that we want to vote again on any deal
that's gone before what we are saying is
if you remember before Theresa May stood
down there was an agreement on the table
that wasn't voted on in which there was
considerable support across Parliament
for different elements of it and that
actually also included the deals that we
did vote on what we are saying is is
publish that withdrawal agreement bill
that was left on the table let us all
see what we agree on and have a grown up
debate about how we move forward build
on where we agree but also seek a deal
to finalise this episode of our
political history so we can all move on
so it's not about voting on a deal
that's gone before but it's about having
a proper grown-up conversation and
moving forward so we can actually get
beyond brexit and talk about those
issues of importance to people in the
country fighting crime poverty jobs in
our economy which sadly have not had the
attention they deserve over the last
three years how optimistic are you that
Boris Johnson will bring adieu
back from Pisa vote on well to put it
bluntly the last week hasn't raised my
confidence by any means but I'm
confident that there are MPs across the
house who will use everything they can
every hour of every day up to the 31st
of October to put pressure on the prime
minister and build assault support
across parliament to achieve a deal I
mean it is about trust and Boris Johnson
has to you know mean what he says he
says he will work to secure a deal and
he has to prove amber rod wrong when she
sells us that not enough energy and
attention and time is going into
securing a deal as opposed to waving the
flag for No Deal the onus is on the
Prime Minister to rise above party
politics to put the country first and
achieve a deal before the 31st of
October I mean the reality is if there
is to be a chance of a deal getting
through it's going to need support from
labour as well now that the Prime
Minister hasn't got majority you get
every single Conservative MP on side
it's not going to be enough Labour's
policy however is to have another
referendum I mean I visited very north
this week how do you think that's going
to go down and some of those key
marginals well I watched your a segment
on on Barry and actually I thought was
really interesting the comments from
people on the streets there I think very
similar to Doncaster but also many
similar to other places in the country
that voted remain I think it expressed a
view of people feeling weary by what has
been going on in Parliament and in
politics and a desire for a strong move
on and I want to be able to you know
look leave voters in the eye and say
look I respected the outcome of the
referendum we have left the European
Union we have control over our laws and
borders but I also want us to be able to
say to remain voters look we respect
your concerns and we will leave in an
orderly way making sure we can protect
our economy protect workers rights our
environmental standards ensure we can
still work on security issues across our
European continent and in that way we
can bring both sides together but we do
need some resolution on this and I do
believe that there are Labour members
and Tory members and even others who
would like to see that happen and don't
forget Sophie it is still Labour's
policy that in a general election our
first task will be to negotiate a brexit
deal you say that it's your policy to
negotiate a brexit deal and yet members
of the shadow cabinet have said that
they would still vote to remain they
still want to have a second referendum
where they would campaign for remain I
mean that's not exactly going to entice
the EU into giving a good brexit deal is
it look there's not a discussion about
you know what is the sort of mood music
use you surround negotiations on some
like Boris Johnson seemed to think that
threatening No Deal is a way forward
others believe actually saying we've
seriously want to get a deal is the
answer look I think what we need to see
is less of the rhetoric but more focused
on getting a deal and look labour has
said it will be committed to negotiating
a brexit deal there's much we already
agree with with what was on the table
from Theresa mate Theresa Mays period as
Prime Minister what we also have in the
party and I'll be honest about it is
strong views who feel that should be put
to a second referendum I don't agree
with that but if there's a Labour
government and there's a voting
Parliament people have to make their own
minds up I will back a Labour government
to secure a deal and to put it into
action I and I know numbers of other
Labour MPs will not support a second
referendum others will have to choose
their own course you say that you want
to see a Labour government of course the
way to get that is through a German
election we be voting for an early
election this week no because I think it
is our duty in this valuable time in
these you know weeks ahead of us before
the 31st of October to secure a deal I
think it's in the interests of all our
parties and the country to focus on that
and then I think once we've done that we
can have a general election and focus on
the issues like poverty as I said and
fighting crime and jobs in the economy
because we all know that without some
resolution here those vital issues for
constituents in Doncaster and Barrie and
elsewhere will not get the
tension they deserve so I believe it's
important the Prime Minister focuses on
bringing us together and that's what he
promised he promised that he would find
a resolution to this he promised he
would work for a deal
he said that no deal was not his
preference well mr. Johnson you know
abide by your words if there was an
election before the brexit deadline do
you think the concept us would win I
think it's hard to tell really at the
moment you know I think that what we
found in 2017 17 that actually Teresa
Mays strategy did not play out I think
around the country there are polarized
views not helped by the prime minister
have to say since he's taken up office
that haven't helped any of the debate my
concern is as well-tuned is not only
will those views be polarized at the
ballot box but actually there may be
many people who are disenchanted with
politics people who voted remain people
who voted leave who may not vote at all
and and for the sake of democracy that's
why I believe we need to find a way
through this and and I urge MPs to my
colleagues across the house you know
back our group MPs for a deal because to
be honest that is the sensible and
reasonable way forward that can bring us
all together and importantly our country
together again so we can get back to
normal politics and just a quick thought
from you while we have you please and
your colleague Diana Johnson is going
through Reis election fight ahead of the
next election back-bencher of the Year
last year are you worried about this I'm
very concerned at a time that we should
be facing outwards we are having these
internal arguments and you know whether
a general election happens before the
31st of October or whether it happens
after we know we're on course for a
general election and and I would have
thought that our main priority is not to
be having a Ministry of selections not
having a GMS to be honest not even
having normal Labour Party meetings that
are often very bureaucratic but actually
you should all be focused on campaigning
so if we're really serious about
recognizing a general election is on the
cards whether that comes sooner or later
let's folk
on that and allow people like Diana
Johnson to do what she does best which B
is being an excellent constituency and
national member of parliament